Transcriber: Kadhim AL-Farttoosi
المدقّق: rana heloun
(موسيقى)
(تصفيق)
مساء الخير، مساء الحب،
مساء الجمال عليكم جميعاً.
أنا اسمي (بغجاتي).
ما أردت أن أريكم إياه في البداية
هو ما الذي لم أغرب أن أكونه،
وما الذي رغبتُ أن أكونه،
كنت أرغب أن أكون عازفًا في البداية
لكن لم أرغب أكون عازفاً تقليدياً؛
عازف، وتوجد موسيقى سواء كان هذا
العازف هو الموزع لها أو أحد آخر
ومن ثم يأتي ويعزفها.
وبأي حال، كل صور الموسيقى
تعطيك طاقة إيجابية
وتعطيك صفاءً داخلي.
ما أردتُ فعله هو أن أدخل
في هذا المجال بصورة مختلفة؛
حيث تستمع لشخص واحد كما لو
أن فرقة كاملة تعزف.
وسنرى الآن
تفاصيل كيف يمكنني أن أكوْن
فرقة كاملة لوحدي
باستخدام التكنولوجيا بالطبع.
ومن هنا أتت تسمية (بغجاتي)،
قد يتسائل الكثير
ما هذا الأسم الغريب “بغجاتي”
البغداديون سابقاً كانوا يطلقون هذه التسمية
على الشخص الذي يعمل في كل الأشغال،
وبما أنني أقوم بعمل كل
شيء لوحدي على المسرح فسميت “بغجاتي”.
أتمنى أن تستمعوا بما سأقدمهُ،
وشكراُ مقدماً لاستماعكم.
(موسيقى)
(تصفيق)